In this video we shall review how to configure default false positive settings.
You can configure whether Enterprise remembers false positives and the criteria it uses to
recognise those false positives.
By default, Enterprise remembers false positive issues in future scans of the same site.
If the same issue is reported again, it is automatically flagged as a false positive.
To configure your settings, you can navigate to the settings cog and select false positives.
From here you can toggle whether to remember false positives for future scans of a site.
And then additionally you can configure how to automatically mark future occurrences of
an issue as a false positive of the same type.
This is either previously marked as a false positive anywhere else on the site or previously
marked as a false positive at the same URL.
Please note, use the previously marked as a false positive anywhere else on this site with
caution.
For example, if you enable it and you flag a SQL injection issue as being a false positive,
then all future SQL injection issues reported for the whole site will automatically be flagged
as false positives even if they arise at different URLs.
Thank you.